hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the test now i don't
really know what this is what i think it
is it's some kind of series of questions
to try to unlock a deeper truth about
yourself or it could be some silly
[ __ ] so if it is some silly [ __ ]
then you won't see this video because it
won't have existed
that's how that works
but i'm going to find out what it's
about now in order to begin this is the
most important part of this entire
experience
you will be asked a series of questions
and you must answer them honestly
now when i say answer them honestly i
don't mean answer them how you'd like to
answer them answer them with truth even
if that's hard to face
okay
we all want to be good people we rarely
want to admit our faults grievances or
mistakes
but you must decide what you truly want
do you want this to work properly do you
want the truth about yourself your
destiny in this world or would you
rather live a lie just to hide from
yourself
i mean
i don't really know it seems a lot more
serious than i thought it might be
the process is very simple in theory
just answer a long series of questions
this music is a little serious what's
difficult is self-analyzing your own
psyche to evaluate the truths in your
own mind and life so that you can
predict your future
you see as long as you're honest with
these questions and answers you'll be
able to see your own future here
i'm sorry what this will tell you things
you already know but don't necessarily
know that you know
i don't really want to know what my
future is i don't really know
as long as the answers you provide to
the questions are asked are a hundred
percent honest and true this process
will simply unlock a part of your mind
that you do not have natural access to
this isn't psychic this isn't a
personality test this is simply nature
is it you sure about that this is you
this is your mind this is simply nature
taking its course this is the human
brain at work unlocking hidden truths
within itself again
i don't know if i want that i was hoping
for just you know
[Music]
fun questions with some funny answers i
didn't should i be nervous about this
while attempting to answer many of these
questions you'll often wonder things
like well this depends on the
circumstances
create your own circumstances in your
mind and answer the questions with a
simple yes or no as you see fit you may
not understand or realize it but your
mind will develop the situation required
to answer your question the way it needs
to be answered
will it
i invite you to grab a drink of water
sit back relax and enjoy the experience
we are about to begin with a series of
questions and provided that you're
willing you're a willing participant we
will be unlocking some substantial
information today here we go what are
you going to do with this information
once you find it are you mining me for
uh
data would you oh would you be all right
with living alone forever
okay i'm constructing it in my mind the
scenario i see me lit by a
light from a fireplace i'm pacing in a
library i don't know why i have a
library i don't even have one now but i
do i'm old
a slight hunch red sweater vest with the
white
they're a beige shirt and green khakis
and loafers really comfy loafers and i'm
alone and the only situation that i
would be alone in is if everyone else in
the world was dead because we're never
truly alone at any moment
in our lives
because we're all in this world together
so everyone else is dead
would i be okay with that
yeah
yeah you know i'm an i'm an introvert so
i mean i don't know happiness i don't
think is the question here it says would
you be all right with living alone
forever and i think i would be honestly
i would be all right with that
yeah
i'm questioning it i shouldn't question
it it's what the scenario in my head i'm
i have i yes
yes
do you like the color blue more than the
color black this is gonna take me
forever keep debating it i am wearing a
black shirt black pants my underwear is
mostly black so do i no i do not like it
more
if you found money on the street and
knew it belonged to some who it belonged
to would you give it back to them yes
without a question
are you sure you want the answers you
seek
i'm not
i'm not sure i do
mostly just because i think i believe i
i think i believe i believe excuse me i
believe i said that i don't really care
to know about my future
and i'm
kind of paranoid about you unlocking
something inside of myself
that seems a little
much i'm not sure
i want the answers i'm not even sure i'm
seeking them
are you afraid of spiders that one's
easier no
i'm constructing a scenario where the
not the balrog what is sh shemoth
shibloth
shimomo
that spider from harry potter i wouldn't
like that but that i don't think that
means i'm afraid of spiders i think
everyone would be afraid of that so no
if you knew you would emerge unscathed
would you jump into molten lava now now
hold on i know what you guys are
thinking
and shut up this is my quiz
i okay unscathed that doesn't mean it's
not painful
and not that that well yes that should
greatly impact my decision but not in
the way that you think it would
i would
yes because i'm emerging unscathed i
know that it's not going to kill me how
many people could possibly say that they
jumped into molten lava and survived
unscathed no one would believe me so i'd
have to film it great content so many
views yes
would you consider yourself to be fat no
would you say that you have lots of
charisma
i didn't wink with the right eye but yes
have you ever wished you could be
temporarily frozen are we talking like
cryogenics here or just frozen and then
come back to life i don't i no this has
never been a desire of mine even in the
situation where it's frozen to go into
the future oh this is one of the things
where it's like you have to construct a
scenario in your head so my scenario is
i don't think this just means like
jump into a frozen lake and be frozen i
think it means be cryogenically frozen
to go into the future and no i would not
want that because i would miss out on so
many experiences that would have
occurred during my life and that i would
miss out on just for some vague idea of
what the future might be you know even
if it was futurama style and you go 2000
years into the future you know i like
the now i like living in the now this is
also the same thing about how i don't
really want to know the future so no
this is all very interesting yes no no
yes yes no yes okay why did you realize
that the last letter of the five
previous five questions would put
together spelled the name satan maybe i
did not realize it no what do you mean
by that i didn't realize it does that
make you uncomfortable not really no
that's kind of cool
are you good at okay are you good at
finding hidden puzzles or clues
apparently not these puzzles just don't
make any god damn sense to me 51.3
you got it buddy
no
my colleague two street tutu perhaps
i could just brute force this this is
some kind of a puzzle and uh
i don't have the brain power to solve it
you know apparently not a y g a f h p o
c a
gaff hip hook
no
are you now wondering what other good
you
shut up you
you shut up
you don't know me
you don't know me
alright you kind of know me i am
wondering
have you been entirely honest with your
answers thus far
i think so but i don't know
are you afraid of the consequences for
answering questions dishonestly to be
perfectly honest yes i don't know what
you're gonna do to me
yes
were you aware that there could be
potential consequences for answering
dishonestly but
were i in the past no
maybe yes now
are you wondering how these questions
began to take a strange turn god stop
reading my mind
stop it
would you consider yourself captivated
does that mean i'm
a captive i am not i'm free man
i yeah honestly i am
i'm super curious but i don't like it
very interesting it's not
it's not it's not
would you consider yourself to be brave
despite all my cowardly screaming i do
consider myself to be quite brave also i
i just noticed that the screen is only
in the top left corner
or at the visible area
what's in the dark areas
i'm brave not saying yes
do you view yourself as someone with
above average intelligence
i do
you probably don't but i do i know i'm
pretty smart i can be very dumb
my
intelligence is like a roller coaster
right when it goes down it goes down
real fast and real low but when it
climbs up it's slow but it gets up there
i think i'm i think i'm above average
have you been looking for hidden
messages in these questions okay i did
once i kind of forgot about the whole
hidden message thing
but i have to say i did
yes
are you wondering which hidden messages
you got
god
yep yeah i am
stop it have you begun to wonder how
long this test will take or how many
questions exist in this session uh
honestly no i have no idea and i have
not been thinking about that because i
live in the present i don't worry about
then that's for other people to worry
about honestly no
would you consider yourself to be a
patient person [ __ ] no aah
the instant gratification monkey is
banging away up there
uh no
do most humans annoy you
what do you mean by that
no
no no no no
most would be the majority of people
annoy me there are plenty of people that
exist that annoy me
that doesn't mean that i think that most
humans annoy me
no do you prefer animals to people i
don't think so i love chica but i also
love amy and
i have friends
i do i definitely do i have friends i
definitely have friends so
no
do you believe in magic
no
flat out
do you believe in god or the existence
of some form of higher power
no
do you fear death no
are you attracted to someone whom you're
not currently in a relationship with no
did you answer that like yes
are you alone
uh
yes
why the music are you sure oh god why
the music you know why you do the piano
boom at that point yes i am sure
if i told you with utmost certainty that
there's someone watching you would will
you believe me
i've got you there i'm a youtuber [ __ ]
i've got
plenty of people watching me right now
would i oh okay but that's not the
question right if i told you with utmost
certainty that there's someone watching
you would you believe me
if you told me if you told me that there
was someone watching me i wouldn't
believe you because you're a video game
you don't know me i keep checking the
camera to look behind me but shut up
i don't believe you
because there's no way
that there's someone
okay how do i how do i answer this i
know that you guys are watching me but
this is what i'm recording in right i'm
not broadcasting this live i think the
question would be different if that if i
were live streaming this versus
recording this
right now in my
recording room there's no one watching
me and i know that if you said that i
would not believe you no
have you wondered who i am
a little bit yeah well have you had
shivers at any point during the session
okay you cannot prove
[Laughter]
when that piano went
at that right time
i gotta say yes
do you feel like you're being watched
well now i do
that doesn't mean that there's anybody
here are you getting a little paranoid
about that that doesn't mean that
there's anybody here
so i gotta say yes but it's not a yes
yes it's
have you considered quitting this
session early no way i'm brave
i'm brave
do you drink water every day yes i do
do you eat at least once per day every
day yes oh yes i do
do you realize that you've missed seven
i don't believe you no i don't realize
that because it's not true you realize
that you just missed another one no i
don't believe you
are you wondering what they are
yeah
but that means i believe you
no
yeah okay
would it bother you to never know
without finding them yourself
no
god no
it would not bother me in the least
is your favorite number seven no
life is short but it's the longest thing
we'll ever do do you agree
i mean yeah that all that that math's
out yeah that maths out
oranges cannot be compared to apples do
you agree depends on the circumstances
they're both they're both spherical
you know they're both fruit no they can
be compared to apples no
venus is sometimes referred to as the
morning star did you know that
did not know that
everyone deserves a second chance do you
agree
yeah
actually i do i do believe that yeah
because this is what this question is is
like can people change right can people
change
and giving someone a second chance
doesn't mean that you have to give them
the same opportunity that the previous
chance
had like there are obviously a lot of
contextual things and this is one of
those contextual things but i think as a
general statement i think everyone does
deserve a second chance you know that
doesn't mean they'll always get it that
doesn't mean they'll always want it that
doesn't mean it'll always occur you
could think of a thousand different
scenarios where you're like oh this this
person shouldn't get a second chance or
this person should you can think of so
many scenarios in general
i think everyone deserves a second
chance because the alternative that no
one it's either a yes or no right
everyone or no one it's not everyone in
some that's not the question everyone
deserves a second chance yes or no
and i'm gonna go with yes
you can do anything you put your mind to
agree big agree on this one huge agree
i'm a living example of it
obedience is more important than freedom
do you agree no i'm a living example of
it i that doesn't make any sense but i'm
saying it with confidence no
underwater adventures sound like a fun
did you realize that the first letters
of the eight previous eight questions
spelled the phrase i love you no
i haven't been paying attention to that
totally forgot again nope you wish to be
loved
i mean i am loved
i think i think okay the scenario in my
head is that like generally as a human
being in my life do i wish to be loved
yes of course meaning that if my love
that i receive ended tomorrow would i
no would i not want that yeah i gotta go
i wish to be loved yeah i think everyone
does
do you have any addictions
i this is one of those things where it's
like i'm kind of addicted to
it's it's a nebulous feeling right but
it's the reason that drives me right i'm
addicted to
um making things and like doing it and
and the reason i'm considering is as an
addiction is because i've talked about
this on videos before in podcast and
whatnot but um it it's something that
has driven me to driven great levels of
success but also it has incredibly
hindered my social life in many ways and
it has cost me a lot in terms of
interpersonal relationships and i think
like
when it's it's something that i am like
it's a great feeling when i put out like
a project that i finished that people
love that feeling there's probably a
word for it that i don't know but um i
am addicted to that feeling i i think i
can say with confidence i i am addicted
i chase that feeling so i think i have
one
do you dislike the color pink no
no
no
no no
no
no no no
no
no no no no no no
i can't do worf safe right now
[Music]
no
no
i punched you in the gonads no there we
go
does the color gray seem depressing
i don't really know
do you enjoy loud music no
do you like to dance no
would you consider yourself normal no
do you love your parents yes
have you ever been lied to
yes
do you get angry often
yes technically speaking okay so
maybe no i've talked about this before
as well i am quick to anger actually i'm
not quick to anger i when i was uh
growing up i was very prone to anger and
i didn't like that about myself and so i
worked very hard to
change that literally i i worked for
years just to get myself to be able to
control my temper you guys have seen me
rage at games that does not mean that i
get angry often
legitimately like this is something like
the majority of the days that i live
i live knowing the things that will make
me angry and i do not pursue them i do
not enjoy them i do not give that part
of me any time of day that doesn't mean
i can't get angry but i do not get angry
often that's the qualifying part of that
question so i will say no and that is
100 truthful
i also don't play rage games that much
for the same reason no
do you hold grudges
no and this is actually a thing that my
dad kind of like embodied he would get
angry at people he i i inherited my
temper from my mom i'm gonna say that
straight up um but my dad had this
like way where he would be angry about
something or at someone one day and then
the next day he'd let it go he he's he
was great at that and i inherited that
from him it's like i don't really hold
grudges and and this is like fluctuate
through life but at this point in my
life i really don't hold grudges
no
have you ever forgiven someone all the
time
have you ever lied oh yeah
do you think flowers are more beautiful
than trees
not really no
have you ever wanted to be an animal
instead of a person no
do you believe you have psychic powers
no
have you ever seen a ghost no
do you dream often yes
do you have nightmares often oh yes
do you suffer from anxiety attacks no
do you suffer from depression no
do you exercise often and stay active
no
not lately god damn you
god damn you
would you consider yourself emotionally
wounded the [ __ ] does that mean
what does that mean
are you wounding my emotions maybe i
don't think i'm emotionally wounded
no
have you ever felt betrayed yes
do you ever feel lost in life oh yeah
would you consider yourself a natural
leader
yes i do
actually this is one of the things like
i never thought that i would answer this
question yes
when i was like in high school or
college but for some reason when i
started doing youtube
i had this realization that i could lead
in certain aspects i i wouldn't say i
have any opportunities to really lead
nowadays i'm not going to charge in any
battlefields but i i wouldn't have
considered myself but it's kind of like
this innate thing that was always there
within me i think a lot of people have
this whereas like
even if you are looking at this question
being like oh no not me you could
because that was me so long ago right
and then through 10 years of doing
youtube and realizing that i had the
potential within myself to take the role
of being a leader like i've directed
many things i've led teams before i've
i've coordinated things as as the head
of them and i think anyone can do that
and i think you guys can do that anyone
can be a leader no one is like i mean
sure someone might be naturally inclined
or the circumstances of their upbringing
got them to the point where they had the
confidence to do that but it really just
all boils down to confidence right and
if you through practice and training
can get to the point where you believe
in yourself others can believe in you
too and that's leadership
among other things but yes
if you could push a button and destroy
oh my god is this the button no no
no
do you sometimes dream of being a hero
oh hell yeah power fantasy dreams all
the time have you ever been bullied oh
yeah all the time have you ever bullied
someone else have i
the piano did not need to hit at that
moment i'm trying to think of a specific
case where i would have bullied someone
and i don't think i did because i was
often the one being bullied right i'm
really questioning this because i feel
like a lot of people have at some point
i've made fun of people all the time but
i don't think i've straight up bullied
someone and this kind of is like more
the word bullying really only works in
school and stuff and i don't think i i
don't think i ever did i was always like
kind of like on the the outskirts you
know like i'm really racking my brain
but i don't think i ever did
no
would you consider yourself to be a
dreamer yeah i think that's a fair fair
assessment do you sometimes hurt
people's feelings unintentionally yes
yes i do and this is another big flaw of
me
and the way i live my life
unintentionally it's specifically
unintentionally yes all the time well
not all the time but i do
do you find
what the [ __ ]
i know this question isn't just about me
or this game isn't just a ques quiz for
me
yes
would you consider yourself to be an
artist
i think so i'm in a creative field and i
do things creatively and i'm really good
at photoshop now so yes
would you consider yourself to be a good
friend
ah this is oh man
this is a tough one right if i want to
be perfectly honest with myself i do not
consider myself to be a good friend
because i just saw my phone light up
with a text from someone who i have not
responded to
in two weeks
legitimately i just looked over at my
phone
and saw a text and a name pop up and i
was like oh [ __ ] i haven't
[Music]
[ __ ]
would you consider yourself to be flawed
yes that's an easy question thank you do
you believe in perfection no oh god no
no not at all no one can be perfect
nothing can be perfect it's the
imperfection that is
what makes us all who we are and nature
be what it is
have you ever stolen from someone
probably like a pencil or something i'm
gonna say yes just because i said like i
don't wanna i'm not trying to make
myself out to be a saint i've probably
stolen from someone at some point
would you ever kill someone under any
circumstances yes
the under any circumstances there's
definitely a circumstance where if i go
if i got to kill someone i i'm going to
kill that person
but it's specific circumstances there's
certain circumstances yes
if you had one day to live would you
tell anyone
i don't think so
you know to be perfectly honest
i because i wouldn't want that to be my
last day this is this is probably all so
selfish of me
if i had one day to live
i would look at it rationally and be
like okay
one day
to
live it's not really time to do anything
that i would want to do it's not really
time
to make anything anymore
it's not time to
get any projects done and if if i tell
other people
god this is the question would i tell
amy
i wouldn't want her to worry you know
one day
[Music]
i don't want
you can't get closure in a day
maybe it's selfish
maybe those are just excuses and maybe
i would just want my last day to me i
look in on myself and i ask my like this
question would i tell anybody
i don't think i would
damn [ __ ] this quiz i don't think i
would
banger video though
i only have 24 hours to live that's a
pretty good day i'll get a lot of views
yeah it would it wouldn't matter at that
point i'd have to i'd i'd rather spend
my last day writing down my thoughts and
trying to like
i don't know get my affairs in order i
guess
you know
tell my parents i love them
don't lay me i love her
but i just don't want them to my last
day can't be with them fretting over the
fact that i'm about to die yeah
no
have you ever told your darkest secrets
to someone yes i think so
do you trust me even though you know
nothing about me i don't trust you one
bit you're a robot you're a program i
don't trust you at all i trust you none
no
do you know who i am no
if i appeared behind you right now would
you scream yeah in
uh a power scream as i grab you in the
throat sorry alexian
i guess i wasn't alone in the room i'm
sorry
yeah
if i told you that i've been behind you
this entire time would that scare you no
because that's a stupid thing to say
i've been looking behind me this entire
time and that would obviously be a lie
no
would you consider yourself to be
empathetic
you calling me an empath
i
can detect that something's bothering
you i think i am empathetic
i in that in the
real meaning of this question in that i
think that i can understand people's
feelings not understand people's
feelings i can commiserate i can
empathize with people yes i am
empathetic
would you consider yourself to be a
romantic no god no
god god
[Music]
no
have you ever been in a physical fight i
have not been in a straight up fight i
have punched people i've never been in
like a real fight
do you count wrestling no all the
scenarios in my head don't they say this
is a no i've never been in a full-on
fight
where it's
mere them
are you prone to headaches or migraines
not really
do you look at the ground when you walk
no the sky in the scenery is too
beautiful also it's bad for your posture
are you attracted to the opposite sex
yes
yes
yes i'm not questioning
whether like the truth inside of me i'm
am i attracted the opposite sex
yes
would you ever shave your head i've done
it
are you attracted to muscular bodies
no
trying to think of like a
there's um
what's uh in the one punch man
the one punch man in one punch man uh
what's her name she's like that track
that track
oh what's her name
lixian marcus rachel you know who i'm
talking about right right here
you know if that's what you're talking
about then yes but i'm assuming in my
construct is you're thinking like
bodybuilding type which
i'm gonna go with no that's that's toned
and fit yeah i'm thinking you're
thinking something else so no you ever
dance when no one's looking oh all the
time
do you trust your best friend entirely i
don't even know who i would call my best
friend but i'm gonna go yes because if
they're my best friend
then there's nothing that's not trust
do you remember your childhood extremely
well yes i do
would you rob a bank if you get to get
away with it
not really i don't think so yeah
do you ever dream about running from a
killer yes i've dreamed about that do
you ever dream about falling off cliff
yep dreamed about that ever dream about
being naked in public
it's not a dream yeah
you ever do you enjoy scary movies or
books sure
you enjoy comedic television yeah
you like being the center of attention
yeah
you feel like someone
you feel like something is always
watching you
are you
are you watching me right now
or
[Music]
uh yeah i'm gonna go with yes on this
one
i was paranoid about cameras you know
yeah i always feel like something's
watching me have you ever wondered what
it would be like to go to space oh yeah
have you ever had an out-of-body
experience
um yeah i think so
usually when i have like waking
nightmares or sleep paralysis yeah
have you ever punched
no but i wish i i wish i could say yes
but i don't think i've ever punched a
nun no you like dogs better than cats
yes
doesn't mean i don't like cats do you
prefer to read more than you prefer to
watch movies ah
i love a good movie i like to read but i
love a good movie i love going to the
movie theater i love that no
are you still wondering why ask if
you've ever punched a nun yeah kind of
do you get starstruck easily nah
you hate going to big parties oh god
yeah
is your favorite part of your birthday
receiving presents nah i don't care
about the presents seriously though have
you ever punched in the nut like really
just bam right in the face nun punch god
i wish i did i wish i could say yes but
i cannot okay
no
let's see did you laugh yeah i did
that's good did you say what the [ __ ] in
your head or even allowed i don't think
i did
i thought most of it i it wasn't i was
attracted to the question i was
disappointed in myself that i didn't
have that experience so no honestly i
did not
yeah
no i didn't are you now eager to somehow
get the opportunity to punch a nuns i
was eager then
i never knew i was eager is this what
you unlocked in my brain the desire to
punch a nun is this what you were
talking about at the beginning of all
this because man i really want to punch
a nun right now
yes
if there's a hell do you think you're
going to it
probably i don't know if there is hell
god pray yeah i'll probably go there not
because i want to experience it's
because i know i could handle it right
my body could handle it do you enjoy
fantasy fiction games yeah
you masturbate frequently oh yeah
are you wondering what constitutes
frequently no not at all i know what you
mean by frequently
see are you more than slightly
uncomfortable right now no
is your mouth dry no kind of wet
does profanity make you uncomfortable
freak
no
do you believe in legendary bees such as
a loch ness monster or bigfoot no
are you poor with money management
no honestly i would say i make some
frivolous purchases but i really don't
go blasting my money all over the place
as much as i say on like distractible or
anything i've talked about where i'm
like i've made this dumb purchase i
don't really waste money i don't like
the idea of wasting money like i grew up
with not having money and i'd like to
keep it that way so i think i'm pretty
good with money management
do you enjoy solving mathematical
puzzles ah not really it's not my
hobbies so enjoy no
do you speak more than one language
fluently i'm learning damn it
takes time
no have you ever visited the country yes
do i enjoy coffee oh yeah do you believe
in demons no
do you believe in angels no
are you afraid of sharks
i gotta go with yes i know
that they don't really kill that many
people and i know but they're part of
the ocean and all that's bad yes
do you prefer baths over showers
this is a toughie i take more showers
but i do love a good bath no i like
showers they're more convenient and you
never really get clean in the bath
because then i start sweating
i don't i shower more i think
now that i'm thinking about i think i
like a shower
no
does smell perfume or cologne give you
headaches uh not headaches i i don't
always like it but not headaches did you
see that shadow move in your room a few
months
no
do you ever hear your name being called
even when you know no one is calling it
i gotta go with yes here
i've heard i have had auditory
hallucinations before yes i have
do you things in your home often go
missing and then reappear later
that's just because i have extreme adhd
and i forget things a lot
uh
[Music]
yes you ever hear footsteps around when
you're not when you're alone
thank god no
god if i did
if i did uh man
i it's the perfect little alarm is like
because chica and henry uh
their their ears are so sensitive to
every noise so like i always even if i'm
having a horrible nightmare and i wake
up from it i know it's not real because
if it was they would be barking like if
i had a nightmare that someone was
coming down the hallway and opening that
door right there
henry and chica would be barking you
know what i mean so no i don't
you ever hear random knocking noises
around you oh yeah all the time you
often look at the same time on the clock
every day you often look at the same
time on the clock every day what does
that mean
no my time management is off i don't
know what you're talking about here have
you ever felt your feet being grabbed at
night while sleeping no
do you have any pets oh yeah
favorite color green
i guess you know yes i know i've said
it's red before but that's because
everything around that i choose is red
but i love
green as a color it's the color of
nature and stuff like this so
in all truth i do love the color green
more than i like red reds is too
aggressive for a lot of things the icon
is red because it's eye-catching i do
think my favorite color is actually
green yes
has been since i was a kid are you
attracted to a family member no
if you won the lottery would you share
the money within it oh yeah yeah if you
could be the dictator of your own
country would you accept the role yes i
would
that's what being a natural leader is
all about i'd probably get shot my first
year in because i would actually try to
help people and then someone else would
take over but i would do it i'd take
that role
if you ever wonder what he would like to
be in prison i've wondered it
do you like fishing no
you like hunting no
you like camping no
do you like guns no
are you getting tired of answering
questions not really no would you
consider yourself to be kinky no
eyes are the wind of the soul you agree
sure
you always keep your promises no
would you ever completely trust someone
who's lied to you no
okay this is
i don't think i would ever completely
trust someone who's lied to me i would
give them a chance to make up for what
they've lied for depending on the reason
of the lie
but i guess i would never completely
trust them i don't know i'm pretty
gullible
the question is would you ever in any
situation completely trust someone who's
lied to you and so
i believe that i'm a good judge of
character and if someone's lied to me
for a reason that is forgivable could i
ever earn their trust back in any
situation there you can think of
situations where you wouldn't
but there definitely would be situations
where someone has lied to me and it
wasn't as disastrous as light or life
destroying but it was pretty bad that it
really like broke up the friendship or
whatever and then you know they redeemed
themselves in my eyes i gave them a
second chance and if if i me with my
friends is like i completely trust my
friends 100
and if they get back to the point where
they're my friend again and i think they
could it's not a lot of situations but
would you ever completely trust him
yeah i would actually yeah
now it doesn't even seem that ridiculous
of course i would
yeah
are you an only child no
do you ever do you enjoy being drunk nah
do you like tattoos
uh
not really
do you enjoy being high in any form no
do you believe you have a soul
no
you cry did you cry this week
no
no
are you upset with someone right now not
that i know of you maybe is there
someone you're not being completely
honest with
daily
daily who do i even interact with daily
no
do you understand how this works yet
nautically
if you answered the question twice your
truth may change it's not just about
answering the questions it's about the
time you spend answering them the
combination you answer them in it's
about many different variables you'd
never guess do you understand
sorry well if your energy
matters
about the time you spend is a
combination of many different
okay i get it
are you wondering if the end of the test
is coming soon based on the previous
question yeah it sounds like it
yeah
if i were to tell you that this entire
process was planted here for you
specifically
you to learn something about yourself
and anyone else that bothers using this
is just a byproduct of its intention
would you believe that
okay
i did uh there's a qualifier right
earlier in this video i did say like
come on but i never actually believed it
was just for me however for just a
moment i did question how i found this
game and if i no one sent me this game i
just came across it on steam i would
never believe that this game was
literally just meant for me no i
wouldn't believe that
are you afraid of being abandoned no are
you afraid of dying alone no
do you worry that one day you'll be
unexpectedly murdered probably are you
always on guard waiting to defend off an
attack no i'm vulnerable always
do you feel like i know you yet yeah
probably you probably got a good idea
have you heard any strange noises while
answering the question besides the
ominous music
no yes i think i did at one point
i think we have enough information
whether you skip questions answer them
honestly or dishonestly took loads of
time to respond or answered quickly
without reading or understanding
properly i've been able to tell
i'm calculating your results i'm
analyzing you very carefully i'm judging
you okay all right what do you got to
say
on what you've told me this is what i
can conclude okay and now this is i
don't even care if this is just all some
joke at the end of it throughout the
process of documenting this and you
watching this you have learned a lot of
things about me and that's already
interesting because each one of you is
coming up with your own conclusions
about who i am as a person isn't that
fascinating
suddenly in the mere time that this
video existed and the duration of the
video
millions of opinions of me
have formed independently
all across the world and i think that's
incredibly fascinating but let's see
what this let's see what this what are
you a witch
thinks of me hmm wizard oh dear
you poor unfortunate soul you've been
hurt before and it's clear that it's
affected the way you look at certain
situations in life whether you realize
it or not
i'm here to tell you right now that it
does not have to be that way you're a
lot stronger than you think you are
you're a lot stronger than you can even
imagine
everything you've been through in life
every way that others have treated you
all the things that have happened
they've all led you to this moment right
here right now even when it seems like
things are falling apart when things
tend to go wrong instead of right you
still keep fighting you're still here
breathing even despite the odds
you're not lucky you're a survivor and
there's a very big difference you need
to fully understand just how incredibly
rare that is in today's world and give
yourself some much needed praise
one thing i can assure you of is that as
long as you continue to fight as long as
you do not give up even if things get
worse despite the odds you can
and you will overcome them
they don't make people quite as strong
as you very often you can survive you
can thrive and you can inspire those who
are struggling by showing them what
happens when you refuse to give in
refuse to surrender and refuse to settle
i'm so incredibly proud of
you and you should be even more proud of
yourself
what the [ __ ]
your secret word is angel remember this
word this will come in handy what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what
angel
my secret word is angel take the secret
word that was assigned to you at the end
of this session and leave it in a
comment for us we will be selecting some
of you based on your answers to be
included in a future project we're
currently working on
don't be afraid this is an opportunity
for you to be part of history this is a
chance for you to be a part of something
greater be sure to know your secret word
in your comments
if you do not wish to be part of the
upcoming project simply leave your
secret word out in the comments and we
will not select your name we appreciate
any and all comments you leave and we
will always read them thoroughly
thank you for taking the time to answer
these questions i know they've been some
help to you and if they aren't yet it
will all make sense very soon trust me
on that
what the [ __ ]
that's very sweet
i was expecting something terrible
that was really sweet
what the hell all right everybody
remember my secret word is angel i gotta
find out what this uh other project they
were working on is what the hell i
thought this was gonna be a nightmare it
kind of was for a little bit but good
god what's wrong with you that was
fascinating that was really fascinating
that was crazy i did not expect that
going into i guess now you know when i
said at the beginning like i don't know
it'll be a video or not i it's a video
but god damn i'll link this in the
description if you guys want to find out
apparently an inner truth about yourself
play this game let me know in the
comments what your secret word is and
what you
did thank you everybody so much for
watching i'm gonna go i'm gonna go think
about stuff have a lovely day
got some introspection done you know not
every day you get a whole bunch of
thinking about yourself done and
so thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you